JOIN THE FIGHT.
SARA SIDNER IS THERE AND SPOKE
WITH SOME OF THOSE HEADING INTO
HARM'S WAY.
>> Reporter: AT THE TRAIN
STATION WHERE THE WORLD'S NEWEST
REFUGEES ARE FLOODING IN, WE
SPOT SEVERAL MEN DRESSED IN
MILITARY GEAR, WALKING WITH
PURPOSE OUT INTO THE COLD WHALE
MOST EVERYONE ELSE IS TRYING TO
COME IN.
WE WONDERED WHO THESE MEN ARE
WHO CAN ONLY SPEAK ENGLISH AND
ARE ITCHING TO GET TO THE BORDER
WITH UKRAINE.
THEY AGREED TO TALK TO US BUT
FIRST NAMES ONLY.
AND THEY ASK US FOR HELP FINDING
A RIDE TO THE BORDER 20 MINUTES
DRIVE AWAY.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE?
>> TRYING TO HELP.
PROTECT FREEDOM.
AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
>> Reporter: ONE OF YOUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS, YOU'RE ALSO HERE.
WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN AND
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> WE DON'T REALLY KNOW RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE SIX MEN
TOTAL.
THEY ARE STRANGERS WHO MET HERE
IN POLAND.
ONE FROM FLORIDA, ANOTHER FROM
SOUTH DAKOTA.
ANOTHER FROM NOTINGHAM, ENGLAND.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WENT OVER BUT
NOT ENOUGH.
IF WE COULD HAVE CRUSHED FASCISM
IN 1936, THAT'S WHAT THIS FEELS
LIKE.
IF WE DON'T STOP IT, IT WILL BE
OUR KIDS FIGHTING THIS FIGHT.
>> THEY ALL CAME FOR ONE THAT
YOU RECALL.
FIGHTING FOR UKRAINE.
MOST SAY THEY'RE VETERANS OF WAR
BUT MATT MAKES IT CLEAR.
HE HAS NO MILITARY EXPERIENCE.
BUT THEY SAY THEY ALL LEFT ONCE
THEY SAW THE BRUTAL ATTACK ON
UKRAINIAN CITIZENS.
JUMPING INTO ACTION A DAY BEFORE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CALLED FOR
MORE FOREIGN FIGHTERS TO JOIN
HIM IN THE FIGHT FOR RUSSIA.
YOU'RE GOING IN WITHOUT A PLAN.
WHY?
>> THOSE PEOPLE ALSO HAVE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
AND SOMEBODY HAS TO STAND UP FOR
THEM.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE U.S.
NOT JUST BRITAIN.
THE WHOLE WORLD IS COMING
TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: IT IS 3:00 A.M.
NO ONE TO PICK THEM UP ON THE
UKRAINIAN SIDE OF THE BORDER.
SOME DON'T EVEN HAVE A JACKET IN
BELOW FREEZING TEMPERATURES.
THEY DISAPPEAR INTO THE NIGHT.
THEY WEREN'T THE ONLY ONES.
THIS FRENCH CANADIAN WHO GOES BY
THE NAME WALLY SAYS HE RECEIVED
A CALL FROM A FRIEND ASKING FOR
HELP IN UKRAINE.
>> SO LAST FRIDAY, MY FRIEND IN
THE JEEP.
HE CALLED ME AND THAT, OKAY, WE
REALLY NEED YOU.
YOU'RE AN EXSNIPER.
CAN YOU JOIN ME?
OKAY.
I'LL DO IT.
>> Reporter: THEY AND THE OTHER
FOREIGN MEN ALL HEADING INTO WAR
WITHOUT THE MIGHT OF THEIR
COUNTRY'S MILITARY TO BACK THEM
UP.